[Music]
It's
God. It's God.
It's God the So,
I want to remind the the the people over
there. I'll read everybody. So, so Adam,
Adam approached me. He says that he
believes that Jesus is a Muslim and he
gave his points why he believes Jesus is
a Muslim. Okay. So, just for the sake of
this, there's more.
>> All right. So, just can you repeat your
your pillars? Okay. So, that everybody
can hear it.
>> All right. So there's more I'm saying.
So at the end of Gospel John, Jesus
says, "Peace be onto you." What do
Muslims say? Peace be upon you. Jesus,
how did Jesus pray? He prayed with his
he prayed with his head on the ground.
What do Muslims do? Pray with their head
on the ground. Jesus never ate pork.
What do Christians do?
>> Eat pork.
>> Jesus never celebrated Christmas. What
do Christians do? Celebrate Christmas.
Jesus grew grew a beard. What do Muslims
do? You grew a beard.
>> How can you reject that? You came to
Time You came to Time Square and that's
your argument.
>> I was streaming. I just saw you were
guys randomly.
>> I'm new to this. I'm serious. You're not
trolling, right? You're being actually
serious.
>> Yes. I'm serious.
>> Okay. He looks really good. It's okay.
So, let's see. What do you do again? Do
that again. So, did Jesus ever do that?
>> Did Jesus ever do that?
>> This is He's being serious. Jesus never
being serious. Jesus didn't do that. He
never did that. He never circle the
cabba.
>> He never did that. He never did that.
>> Did he circle the Cabba?
>> He's God, man.
>> The cabba is a is a place to pray. It's
a place. Did he circle the Jesus circle
the cabba out of
>> the kabat?
>> Did Jesus circle the cabba?
>> He's asking. He's going to help me. I'm
>> I'm learning. I'm learning. Let me tell
you. He's going to tell me. I'm
learning. Wait.
>> Did he do it or not?
>> Let me ask you. Did Jesus He's not
a place of worship. That That's a place
>> I know. Did Did Jesus circle the Cabba?
>> Did Jesus circle the Cabba? Yes.
>> I'm not eligible on this. I'm a boxer.
>> I'm into this. I got you. So, the answer
something happened to you though. I got
you. So, let me let me Let's deal with
this. Okay. So, Jesus never bowed down
or never sucked the Cabba. So, he didn't
Muslims do that. So, he's not like a
Muslim. He bowed down.
>> All right. Good. So, now he says that
Muslims bowed down when they pray. When
they pray, right? They prostrate. And so
did Jesus. When Jesus prostrated, he
prayed. Now, my my question is this,
Adam, let's think about this, okay?
Critically, does it matter who we
prostrate to when we pray?
>> Doesn't matter who we prostrate to. What
do you mean?
>> Like, so like for example, if I were to
prostrate, let's say I believe in God. I
say I believe in God,
>> right? One God only. But the one God
that I'm prostrating to is a statute in
my backyard.
>> Is am I a Muslim?
>> You don't. So you're trying to say we're
asking
>> not hypothetical. I don't really know.
>> Okay. Good. So it matters who I
prostrate to, right?
>> To God. It got to be to God. Just God.
Very good. Right. Right.
>> So when you say that I have to prostrate
to God, just simply prostrating when you
pray doesn't make you a Muslim. You got
to prostrate to the actual God. Correct?
>> God. Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. So when you say that Muslims
prostrate to God, who is this God that
you're talking about? Like give me some
qualities of his.
>> Allah.
>> Allah. Allah means God.
>> Okay. But what what what about cuz a lot
of people call their things God.
>> What language did Jesus speak? What
language did Jesus speak? Tell us. I'm
asking you.
>> I don't know. I'm asking you. I don't
know what he speak
but notice one thing but I need you I
need you to deal with this don't don't
please don't walk away don't walk away
I'm not walking away I'm still here so
look asking questions I know language
speak my brother I asked you before you
asked that
>> you're saying nothing you're saying no
Adam listen I I have no problem going
point for point what you got down okay
my my thing is I'm not here to like mark
you I want us to go to get some
understanding. Okay. So, all right. So,
what language did he speak?
>> I know I I know you asked that, but
before that because I asked you
something before that we all pray to
God. Yes.
>> Okay. So, so I so I asked you I asked
you what qualities do does Allah have
>> that identifies him.
>> God is the greatest.
>> Allah is the greatest.
>> All right. Give me something else.
>> The all forgiven.
>> Forgiven. Okay. Nice. What else?
>> Say again. What else? What What is
something unique about him?
>> He's the most forgiven. All right. most
forgiven. Does he have any children?
>> Children like like prophet
>> any any sons?
>> Does he have sons in any sense?
>> No, he can't have no God has no son.
>> Very good. I got you. Okay, good. So,
can you be a Muslim and believe that
Allah is your father?
>> Father God, we say God.
>> So, can you be a Muslim and believe he's
your father?
>> What do you mean father?
>> God, we say God.
>> I know. I get you. So, that's my point.
You Muslim, as Muslims, you believe God,
Allah is your God, not your father,
right?
>> What do you mean father? In any sense,
if you're his begotten son, adopted son,
spiritual son, is Allah a father in any
sense like we're son of gods technically
like you could say we're sons of god.
We're all sons of gods,
>> right? So the problem if all of us are
we're God's creation, right? So so
>> Jesus Jesus was God's creation. He
worshiped God. He came to this world to
spread the message of one God only. And
you guys are you guys are worshiping a
human. Okay. So this this is why you're
new also.
>> So I'm not going to like it said it.
Thank you. I appreciate you, you know.
Yeah,
>> I'm I'm not going to like hold it
against you.
>> It's also in the Bible.
>> Jesus was not all knowing. God is all
knowing. You're switching. You're
switching something.
Look, we're going for point for point.
Okay. All right. So, you're not
>> I'm dealing with a point for point.
You're being blind. Adam, you got you
got to listen to me, too. You're being
blind to Okay, if you say that. So,
look.
>> So, you said that we're all sons of God,
right? We're all sons of God cuz we're
his creation. That's what you said,
right?
>> Say father, we say God Allah,
>> but but you just said we're all his
sons, right?
If you could say it like it don't mean
we're sons of God. Just
>> so metaphorically spiritual we're sons
of God.
>> The prophets the prophets are sons of
God. Okay. Do you have a Quran verse
that says that?
>> You're just as God.
>> I don't have the Quran on me. What do
you mean?
>> Okay. So, is there a Quran verse
anywhere that identifies us or the
prophets? He said the prophets. Does the
Quran say the prophets are the children
of Allah? As I told you, in the Bible,
Jesus does say that he is he is not God.
Okay. So can you all right here's the
point here's the point the point is this
look look the point is this in the Quran
in chapter 19 it says they say that
Allah has a son they have uttered an
atrocious thing that the most
beneficient has a son far be it from him
that he has a son
has a son that's that's that's not what
we're talking about right now I'm asking
as a Muslim can you believe that God has
a son
>> no very good okay good I agree with you
that as a Muslim you cannot believe
believe that God has a son. Now, here's
the point. When Jesus was prostrating,
who did he say God is?
>> Who did Jesus say God is?
>> Yeah. Who did he What happened to the
Hold on. Just real quick.
>> She's fixing something.
>> Testing, testing, testing, testing. We
got to wait for this to come out.
>> Testing, testing, testing, testing,
testing, testing. Let them distract
>> testing. Testing. All right. We All
right. So when Jesus is frustrated, who
did he say that God is that he's
prostrating to? We are the slaves of
God.
>> Yeah. But who did Jesus say his God is?
>> Who did he say his God is?
>> Yeah. When he was frustrated, he
worshiped God. Jesus put his head on the
ground.
>> What did he call him when he worshiped?
>> What did he call God?
>> He spoke Aramaic.
>> What did he say?
>> Allah.
>> Nope. He didn't say that.
Let me let me
>> What's the definition of God in Aramaic?
>> Well, the the definition and the
translation are two different things.
But go on Google right now. Go on Google
right now.
>> I I got you. I got you here. In Aramaic
is Allala. I got you. But look, when
when you're referring to Jesus praying,
prostrating when he prayed. What he said
was he said, "Aba, father." He said,
"Aba, father." That's aba is Aramaic for
father. He says, "Aba, father, if it be
possible, oh, show you where?" Okay, go
to Mark.
>> Yeah, I got you. Go to Mark chapter 14.
Mark 14. You can you can you can Father
is not a human thing. father is not but
notice here's the important thing that
you cannot be a Muslim and believe that
Allah is your father you know honesty
god logic you're very lost I watch your
some of your videos getting an answer
listen
I'm saying I'm staying
I'm just saying I'm new and I'm learning
but I'm not I'm not I'm not learning
anything that you guys actually don't
you guys
>> we us Muslims we love Jesus we follow
Jesus
>> we got you brother listen listen
here's he's he says he says okay so it
says this he says sit here while I pray
and he took with him Peter and James and
John and began to greatly distress and
troubled and he said my soul is very
sorrowful even to death remain here and
watch going a little further he fell on
the ground and prayed that if it were
possible is our my passion and he said
aba father all things are possible for
you remove this cup from me he called
god father he cannot be a muslim because
for him god is a father and in Islam God
is a father to no one so so do you
understand the point so if if Jesus is
if Jesus is theible
>> the bible is not god's word so it
doesn't matter what okay
the bible has been changed
>> it's cool it's cool
>> it's cool it's
Bro, the Quran has never been changed.
>> Adam, Adam, I got you. You guys really
lost. So, listen there, brother. Here's
his point, guys. His point is now at
first he said that Jesus prostrated when
he prayed. That shows that he's a
Muslim. We showed him what Jesus said
when he prostrated and prayed by calling
God his father. Adam and he he
acknowledged you cannot be a Muslim and
believe Allah is your father. So,
therefore, Jesus is not a Muslim because
he says that God is his father. But
Adam's retort is is that the Bible is
corrupted. So here's the question now.
So if the Bible is corrupted, how do you
know that Jesus prostrated when he
prayed?
>> Oh, everybody is.
>> How do you know he prostrated?
>> You're you're believing something that's
been changed.
>> Okay, God loves you. You seem smarter
than this, but honestly, it seems like
you're just doing this for YouTube.
You're actually Muslim deep down inside.
We believe the question. Yeah. Why two
people?
>> Three people on you. Four people on you.
Answer the question. We love Jesus. We
follow Jesus.
>> Yes, we do. We love Jesus.
>> No distractions.
>> If he didn't know, if he doesn't know,
then he's ignorant. We don't know.
>> No distractions. No distractions.
>> We follow Jesus. We believe that Jesus
is a prophet. How do you know? How do
you know he prostrated Adam and a
messenger of God? Yo, show me any. How
do you know he prostrated? Please.
>> Show me any verse in the Bible.
Unambiguous state where where it says
Jesus is God. Show me. I'll do that
next. I'll do that next. Show me right
now. I'll do that next. But first, but
first, there's only one God. Muslims and
Christians. Adam one point at a time,
brother. Look, one point at a time.
>> That's mic. I don't got no I keep giving
you the mic, too. We're sharing it.
>> No, I just I got this mic.
>> Okay. Look. So, how do you know that
Jesus prostrated when he prayed? How do
you know? Where do you get that from?
>> Jesus, Abraham, Isaac, Joseph, all put
their hand on the ground when they pray.
>> Where do you get humbled himself? And
but where do you get that from?
>> So, I'm not eligible, but I saw Ali Dawa
and she cook you and they know I just
came here. Yo, I You know what's crazy?
Yo, relax. You know what's crazy? Yo, I
came here to do to do a stream. I was
going to do a stream saying prove Jesus
was Christian in 2009 and I saw you
randomly.
>> Okay.
>> It's a sign from my love for you to be
look
from God for you to come to the truth.
Look, I respect your semihumility, bro.
It's like cuz look, you're humble enough
to say, "Look, I'm I'm new to this. I
don't have that much knowledge, but at
the same time say that I'm lost and I
don't you know, I got to change book."
But I know, but let me let me say this,
please. Let me say this. So, here's the
point. This is the crux of the matter.
Yeah,
>> you affirm that Jesus prostrated. You're
speaking uh you're speaking like that's
a fact, but you don't know that you're
getting that from the very Bible you're
saying is corrupted. The only place you
get that Jesus prostrated is my Bible.
So the same verse I showed you that
Jesus prostrated and called God father
is the very verse that works against
you, you're pulling from that verse
while saying it's corrupted. So it's
either that verse is authentic and wait
listen. It's either that verse is
authentic and good enough for us to get
factual information of how Jesus
practiced his religion or it's corrupted
and you don't know if Jesus prostrated
or not, you know. So, is it authentic
and we know Jesus prostrated or it's
corrupted and we don't know if Jesus
prostrated at all? Which one is it?
>> Okay. So, did Jesus did Jesus walk on
this on this earth as a human being?
Asking your question. Changing the
subject,
>> bro. I don't know. He just yapped about
like a thousand. I do I do professional
boxing. If I have a beginner, if I got a
beginner, I'm going to go slow. I'm
going to go You got to take it easy on
me. If there's an amateur, I'm going to
go easy. I kind of slow. All I got to do
is look up the video and cook you.
>> So So you agree with Ali Daw that
triangles and squares contradict each
other
>> and so you agree with you agree with
that textual varian make a book
corrupted?
>> No. Now you're just making up. How do
you ignore everything? No. No. No. How
do you ignore how do you ignore
everything that's that's wrong? The
Quran is just a rectified Bible.
>> Because the the Quran says, we're
warning you. You can't be this guy.
>> That's a good question. His question is,
how can I ignore something like the
Quran that's completely true and the
Bible's been changed. Here's how. Here's
why. Here's why. Please, sister, do not
say anything to them. There's no proof.
>> Here's why. Cuz he's using as a
distraction. Do not do not say nothing
to him. Trust me. Here's the reason why
I'm able to ignore the Quran. The reason
why is because the Quran tells me,
listen, Adam, you listening? Yeah.
>> The Quran tells me to judge by the
gospel. So, if I judge by the gospel,
the Quran tells me I'm a good Christian.
If I judge by the gospel, I have to
judge the Quran as false cuz it
contradicts the gospel. Now, if the
gospel is changed, you listening?
>> Yeah, I'm listening.
>> If the gospel is changed, then why is
Allah telling me to judge by a changed
book? 0 547. By the way,
>> I'm not going to lie. Anything that
comes out your mouth, I don't believe
that [__] bro.
>> I've seen so many videos.
>> It's in the sides. It's in the sides.
>> Yo, Bible itself.
>> Hey,
just really quick. Really quick. What's
the only thing we do around here, y'all?
>> We do what?
>> We just what?
>> All right. So, look. So, look.
>> I'm read. I'm going to take you out from
the Bible where where it's all wrong.
Where they said different ages,
different but has never been changed.
>> All right, cool. So if if the Bible is
full of contradictions, that means that
Listen, you I'm going with you, Adam.
You give it your own meaning. Bible if
the Bible meaning I got you. If the
Bible is full of contradictions, then
the Quran is confirming a book full of
contradictions. So you don't get out of
this problem. saying that my book is
messed up is just going at Allah because
he says my book is good.
>> There's there's so many errors. There's
so many errors been written.
>> No, there's so many errors in the Bible,
man. I'm telling you, there's so many
errors. It's crazy how you guys just
letting the errors go. How is that word
of God if it's not here? Here's verse
47.
>> Show me the verse.
>> Verse 47 at the top right here.
>> Read it. Read it. Oh, y'all ganging up
on me. Where's backup? Let me FaceTime,
bro.
Where is it? Where is it? 47. 47. I
can't see nothing. I got the mics up.
Let the people of the Enjil judge by
what Allah has revealed therein. And
who's whose ever does not judge by what
Allah has revealed. Such are the fif the
rebellious disobedient.
So, so you see how it tells me to judge
by the gospel or else I am of the
rebellious.
>> All right. Now, let me put here hundreds
of things in the Bible.
>> Wait, here's the question. I'm going to
grant you all of that. Look, I'm going
to grant you contradictions. I'm going
to grant you immorality in the Bible.
I'm going to grant you a inconsistency
in the Bible. Why is the Quran saying
that a book full of inconsistencies,
contradictions, and changes is true and
I have to judge by it?
>> It's not. You give yourself the own
meaning.
>> All right. So tell me give yourself the
own meaning. You say sons of God or you
just make up your own meaning. So tell
me you're too lost on this. I'm saying I
got you. So tell me what does it mean
when Allah tells me to justify the
gospel?
>> As I told you, you're you're a
professional at this. I'm I'm here
trying, you know, you know. Yo. Yo, let
me debate her. Let me debate her, bro.
Let me debate her, bro.
Look, you know, you don't need to put
time in the mic. He's running.
>> Now, let's pull out the Bible. Now,
let's pull out the Bible. Right.
>> Let's pull out the answering the
question.
>> Let's pull out the Bible. I told you I
don't know. I don't know. There's people
who have it memorized. They have it
memorized.
>> Okay. So, pause here. Look, we got
memorized. Notice how you remember you
said when we go through with a beginner,
you go slow with them, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, look, I notice I'm not coming
against you. I'm not trying to like, you
know, get you gota points or nothing
like that. Okay? So, listen to the point
I'm making.
>> Yeah.
>> Look, I need you to pause for a second.
But you're not listening.
>> I ain't listening. I got ears.
>> No, bro. Cuz you're not hearing nothing
I'm saying. I
>> I swear I can hear you. Trust me.
>> Okay. So, what I need you to do, think
about this with me. Okay. If the Bible
is full of contradictions and
inconsistencies,
why does the Quran tell me to judge by
that book? Why
>> the in the Bible and the Quran are
different?
>> Awesome. Hey,
>> we we got a new contestant, ladies and
gentlemen.
>> We got a new contestant.
>> Our new contestant.
>> And ladies and gentlemen, what is the
name of our new game show? What's he in
jail? What's he in jail? What's he in
jail? What's he in jail?
>> All right. All right. All right. All
right. Ladies and gentlemen, we got a
new contestant in our new show. What's
the angel? Adam is here and he said that
what I have the Bible is not the same as
the angel in the Quran. So that means he
knows what it is. So Adam, what's the
angel? That doesn't mean what it is. I
read it on my chat.
Shout out chat, baby. Shout out chat.
Shout out to the chat, man.
Oh, it's cute. Are you a Muslim?
>> Step up, brother. Step up.
[Applause]
>> All right, go ahead. Wait. Everybody
calm down. Everybody calm down.
Everybody calm down.
>> Hey, guys.
>> Everybody. Everybody calm down.
>> Everybody calm down.
>> All right. All right. All right.
>> So, we got another Muslim contestant who
stepped up.
Baby,
>> we all good. We all good.
>> How long is this video?
>> It's all good. It's all about
take it off.
>> All right. All right. All right.
>> He's just getting ready. Just getting
ready.
>> You ready?
>> I want to answer a question that you
made before to Adam.
>> About what's the Did you ask if Jesus
ever called the father Allah? He does.
>> No, no, no. That's not what I asked.
>> No, I was talking about I didn't ask
that
>> before. You were you were asking for
clarification about that. And when Jesus
tell if I'm not mistaken, Mary, he says,
"I'm going to my father, your father, my
God, your God." He spoke in Aramaic,
meaning he said, "I'm going to my father
Abba, your father. My Allah, your
Allah." So he's the same Allah.
It's okay. You know what? For the sake
of this, for my brother here who came up
very respectfully, I'm going to go.
Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely. My name is
everybody, by the way.
>> I know. I seen the ortho. You did a
little, you know, you agree that Yahweh
is Jesus. Is Yahweh in a sense?
>> He's got more knowledge than me to be
honest. But is Jesus is Jesus Yahweh? Of
course. Of course not.
>> Of course not. Oh, then then I won the
debate.
>> Okay. How?
>> Okay. Because because he admitted that
Jesus is Yahweh.
>> That No, he's talking about what Paul is
teaching.
>> No. Yeah. Believe that.
>> But the debate was the debate was is
Jesus in the in the New Testament. So in
the New Testament, Jesus is Yahweh,
right?
>> According to Paul, yes.
>> Okay. So now I want to debate. So I want
>> let me clarify. If the debate was does
the New Testament teach that it that
Jesus is the most high? Sure. Okay.
>> We got a reigning champ here. Even the
Muslims admit that he he won the debate.
You
>> No, no, it's no problem. I have no
I'm being honest because that's Paul and
whatever it's called. That's Paul's
teachings. That's Christianity. No,
that's Paul's teachings. Jesus was a
Muslim because he prayed. That's the
whole point, right?
>> He prayed to the one true God. Who's the
only true God? John 17:3 says Jesus
Jesus is looking up and he says, "Oh
father, may this be eternal life." What
is eternal life? To go to heaven, right?
That they may believe in who? The holy.
Sorry, I spat out. My bad. My bad. I get
a little hyped up. It's all I got to
take a breather there. Um, but that they
may know you. The U is not to the Holy
Spirit. But you is not to himself.
Obviously, unless you'd be crazy. We
don't believe that.
>> He was just giving his interpretation.
>> He's talking to the Holy Ghost.
>> Yeah. I I I have no problem admitting
that Paul teaches in the New Testament,
Jesus is the Muham. No problem. The
point is, is Jesus truly God?
>> Okay. All right. So, Muslim. Yeah.
Muslim, right? So, you so you
acknowledge that Jesus is teaching that
the only true God is the father. Is that
right?
>> That is 100% correct. The father Amen,
brother. Amen. that the father is the
only true God, not the Holy Spirit, not
I got you. So, here's my question.
>> What's your question?
>> Is Allah his father?
>> Sure. In a sense. No problem.
>> No problem.
>> No, y'all are brainwashed. You're too
good.
>> Y'all are already brainwashed. Oh my
god. I have Look, look. You're still
learning.
>> Get ready to say your O. Get ready to
say the O's because look, we have no
problem. We don't you the Quran and
Islam traditionally does no no longer
uses that relationship of the wording of
father. Why? Because unfortunately you
look at Catholicism now God is a mother
or Mary
>> that's not Catholicism. Please don't
misrepresent.
>> Catholicism doesn't believe that God no
let me correct. Let me clarify.
Catholicism doesn't believe that Mary is
the mother of God.
>> They don't. No. You said that that God
is the mother. We don't Catholics don't
believe
>> I'll take that. I'll take that. I
misspoke. What I'm saying is when you
have that when you use those wordings,
father, brother, sister, roommate. We
don't believe God has a father, a
brother, sister, roommate or mother of
you just affirm that Allah is the father
of Jesus in a sense.
>> In a sense, you're using the term.
>> Sure. Is he ontologically? You look,
there are only three types of sunships.
Everybody can please correct me if I'm
wrong. Three types. Either you are a
literal son of God like my father like
your own father, your dad, and your mom
came together and created you just like
me. That's a literal literal father
sunship fathership or you have an
adopted or you have a metaphorical
obviously God didn't adopt us go to the
legal court sign some paperwork nor is
he our physical father he didn't have
intercourse with another woman to have
us sorry about the mic he is
metaphorically our father no problem can
I respond to this go ahead so so I I
like what you're saying you left out one
other option that God doesn't need a
mate and that he in of himself can beget
a son of his own nature without any
help.
>> Say one more time. One more time.
>> That God can be get a son from his own
self, from his own essence, without a
mate. That he doesn't need a helper or a
mate.
>> He doesn't beget.
>> That's what your belief says. And I and
I agree. But that's an option.
>> Okay. So, so you said that Jesus is
Allah's son in a sense.
>> Okay. Do you have a verse that says that
in the Quran?
>> Do I have a verse that says what? That
Jesus
>> Do you have do you have a verse in the
Quran that says that that Jesus is
Allah's son in some sense? That's that's
special pleading because then I can say
does Jesus say I am God? He doesn't.
>> No, you're special pleading when you
when you say that Allah is a is has a
that Jesus is the son of Allah in some
sense with no source with no backing no
basis. You're special pleading. I'm not.
>> You're you're asking me do I believe
Jesus is the son of the Jesus the son of
God right? Is there a sunship? I'm
saying if you want to ask me that
question I'm not going to say the Quran
because the Quran does not say that.
>> Very good.
>> But is Jesus the son of God in a
metaphorical sense? We have no problem
accepting that. Is it in the Quran? Is
it in the Quran? No, it's not in the
Quran. I got you. Just like Pause there.
Wait, pause there. Please one one
second, please. One last point. Just
like I'm going to ask you, does Jesus
say, "I am God. Worship me." Of course
not. You're not going to find it from
Genesis to Revelation. It's
non-existent.
>> Got you. I got you. So, if if we were to
do this this way, notice notice I'm not
asking you for verbatim words. I'm
asking you simply if the Quran teaches
that Jesus is Allah's son in any sense.
Now, if we can be honest with this,
let's be honest with what the Quran
says.
>> Does it teach that Jesus is Allah's son
in any sense?
>> Does it teach that Jesus is Allah? That
Jesus is Allah's son in any sense?
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Okay. So, if it doesn't teach that that
Jesus is Allah's son in any sense, how
can you as a Muslim accept a theology
that doesn't exist in your Quran?
>> Because it's an on It's not in an
onlogical sense.
>> No, no. Listen, listen, listen. Stop.
Look, notice how you keep going to
ontological.
>> I want to answer your question. I want
to answer. Okay, good. So, I'm not I'm
not only talking about onlogical in any
sense, right? We already affirm that the
Quran does not teach that Jesus is
Allah's son in any sense. Whether it's
metaphorical, right? Okay, good.
>> I'm not making the claim. Good. Good.
I'm not saying Jesus is God's son.
>> Well, well, you you did just say cuz I
asked you is is Allah the the father of
Jesus. You said yes in a sense.
>> Right. So you're so you're affirming
that the Quran does not teach that Jesus
is Allah's son in any sense while at the
same time accepting that Jesus is
Allah's son in some sense.
>> I'm speaking I'm speaking your language.
>> No you're not speaking. It's not about
wait just really quick. It's not about
my language. It's about whether or not
Jesus is in line with what the Quran
teaches. Cuz let me ask you this. Can
you be out Can you go against the Quran
and still be a Muslim? Uh, give me an
example. I don't know what you mean.
>> So, if I were to if I believe that Allah
had had partners, if
>> Can I say something? Can I say
something? Hey, yo, whoever's throwing
water bottles, bro, it's two Muslims
right here, two Christians right here.
We're talking, it's all love, none of
that hate stuff, please.
>> Yeah. Yeah. What are you saying? So, um
um can you go against the Quran? Like,
let's and something major example. Yeah.
Yeah. So, let's let's say I believe that
Allah has a has a partner, right? That
he has a companion. Okay. Right. Listen,
can I be a Muslim and affirm such a
belief?
>> No, you can't.
>> Okay, so something as major as that,
right? You cannot be
>> that specifically saying that God has an
is is in association with other brother,
sister, sister, mother, roommate, you
can't be a Muslim, of course.
>> All right. Now, why can't I?
>> Because that goes against a fundamental
belief, a principle, which is ahead. God
is one. Just like Jesus says in John
17:3,
>> the word father is abrogated. The word
father is just like the Bible is
abregated. The word, the word bal, you
know.
>> I got you. So, there's many sons of gods
in the Bible. There's many sons of God.
I got so Allah's good. So, Allah's
qualities can be abregated.
>> No, no. Allah's name can be abregated
because in the Old Testament, no. Uh,
sorry. The the God All right.
>> The God of the B, right? Old Testament.
Hold on. Let me ask you a question. In
the Old Testament, does God abrogate the
name Bow for himself?
>> He He never affirmed that he was bow. So
why would he say no, you no longer
should call me B?
>> Because that's what they were calling
him.
>> He he didn't affirm that for himself.
>> Okay. I don't know. I don't know.
>> So there's a difference between what
people say about God and then what God
affirms for himself. Wouldn't we agree?
>> What what I what I remember what I
remember to my limited knowledge.
>> You're right. That's in Hosea. He says,
"You shall no longer call me Baal."
That's because these particular Jews
were associating him with that false
god. He says, "You shall no longer call
me Ba'al." He doesn't affirm that for
himself. That's what they were calling
him. And he addresses that.
>> So there's a difference between We as
people addressing God as something
versus God affirming a title for
himself. Make sense?
>> I see what you're saying.
>> So does So what we're talking about is
Allah is Yeah. Allah denies the term
father for himself. He denies any
sunship, right? That he has a son or
companion or anything like that. So you
can't be a Muslim if you're affirming
that Allah has children in any sense
according to the Quran.
>> I'm just again I'm just speaking in your
language. You guys are the ones that use
the word son and and father and all.
That is that Islamically consistent?
>> No, not Islamic because we're in a
different time now. In the time in the
in the time of Jesus, you would say, uh,
father, no problem in that sense because
it was the correct sense. Just as we
would today, we say
because we say God is only one and we
believe Muhammad as the final messenger.
In the time of Jesus, we would say the
same thing. God is only one and Jesus is
the messenger.
>> In the time of Jesus, would you say he's
the son of God?
>> The son of God in the correct sense.
Sure. In the correct term.
>> So you're doing it again. So, so look,
when you're saying look, but but you're
doing it again.
>> Look, notice equating him to God.
>> It doesn't matter if you're saying it
doesn't matter. You can say that Jesus
is a son who's lesser than Allah. No
worries. But guess what? If you're
saying that Jesus is the son of Allah,
guess what the Quran says about that? It
says, say to Muhammad, if Allah were to
have a son, I would be the first to
worship him. So Allah says in the Quran
that if he has a son, that he's
deserving of worship.
>> In what sense?
>> In what sense? If if he's worthy of
worship, what in what sense does that
make him?
>> Meaning God.
>> Exactly. So So if he's the son of God,
then he's God himself.
>> You're literally saying you're you're
bringing two different times and you're
using languages of two different times.
>> Is it the same religion in both times?
>> What the same religion? What do you mean
by the same religion?
>> Is it was Look, you're saying that Jesus
practiced Islam, right?
>> What is Islam? What is Islam? Islam. How
do we define Islam?
>> You don't have to tell me this. Look,
just let's just affirm this simply.
Okay.
>> You believe that Jesus was a Muslim,
right?
>> Correct. By believing by believing in
>> the one true God and not associating
partner.
>> Exactly. So you Muslim, right? Is that
correct?
>> Sure. Sure. I'll go with you. So, so, so
let's go with this. So, that means that
Jesus was practicing the religion of
Islam in his time. Correct.
>> Hold on. Pause.
>> Is that correct though?
>> Let me let me let me answer your
question. I'm going to answer your
question. I'm not running anywhere.
>> You just said, "Is Jesus a Muslim?" We
just agreed the definition of a Muslim
is the one who worships only one God,
none other. Can we agree on that?
>> I'm granting you the definition. I don't
believe I'm giving that to you. Now, can
you answer? No, I don't.
>> So, what do you believe in Muslim?
>> It doesn't matter. That's that. Look,
that's a red herring. Okay.
>> You assure it.
>> I'm granting it for you. Yes. For the
sake of this argument, I allow that
definition
>> for the New Testament.
>> It's not about a servant now.
>> No, it's not, bro. No, it isn't. No, it
is. Different things. Look, focus. I
need you to answer the question here.
Okay. Did Jesus practice Islam?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, it doesn't matter what time he
lived in, the religion was the same.
Correct.
>> Believing in one God. Yes.
>> Okay. So, that means that you can't say
that the religion is subject to its
time. It's the one religion. So, if
you're saying that in Islam, you cannot
ever say that Allah has any children in
any sense. Then it wasn't okay for Jesus
to say it back then. It's the same
religion
>> in a divine sense. In a divine sense,
you can't
>> stop saying. Look, brother, what's your
name? Adam.
>> Adam. My name's Avery again. Look,
>> I'm not listen, Adam. Let's let's let's
let's make sure we eliminate this at all
because I don't want us to get stuck on
this.
>> Me neither.
>> Do we agree? Okay. Any sense includes a
divine sense, metaphorical sense,
adoptive, spiritual, analogical, all of
that in any sense of the word. That's
what it all encompasses. Okay,
>> let's go with it.
>> All right. So please do not for the sake
of this argument going forward don't
appeal again and say not in the divine
sense.
>> But that matters. It matters what sense.
>> If we're saying you're saying no sense.
You said no any sense.
>> What did I say in no sense?
>> What are you talking about
>> brother? You you just agreed that the
Quran does not teach that Allah has
children in any sense.
>> It doesn't it doesn't teach that.
>> So that includes a divine sense, right?
>> Sure. Okay. Good. So we don't have to
say that anymore. So now in regards to
this, if someone at any time is if
someone anybody at any time is affirming
that Allah is their father,
>> okay,
>> are they consistent with Islam?
>> That's the crazy. It depends on the
person. What do you mean? It depends on
the person. What do you What do you
mean?
>> So Islam is subjective. Islam is not is
not an objective truthful truthful
religion, but it's based on time. It's
based on culture and it's based on your
opinion.
>> I mean, I don't know. I don't know what
you're trying to say.
>> Look, when you when you when you focus
Hey, I am when you say that it depends
on who the person is, right? That means
that you have now renegaded Islam to
subjectivity. It is now dependent on
your personal opinion, culture, and time
frame. So, it's not an objective
religion. It's based on how we feel. As
long as that person is believing in one
true God just like Jesus believed that's
that's what Islam is. That's what Muslim
being a Muslim is. We agree. We believe
in one true God. Are we now Muslim? Are
we now Muslim?
>> Who do you believe is the one true God?
>> The father, son, and holy spirit.
>> So why are you going against Jesus?
>> No. Are we Muslim?
>> Are we Muslim?
>> If you believe the father is the one
true God. You're a Muslim.
>> We believe that the father, son, and
holy spirit are the one true God
together. Are we Muslim?
>> Of course not.
>> Thank you. So it's not subjective. It
there. So when you say that you're a
Muslim and you have the idea of the true
God, you have a specific concept you're
appealing to. It can't just be anything
of anybody's imagination.
>> One true God can be three true gods.
>> Does the I got you. Does the true belie?
>> Hold on. I believe in one true God. I
answer you.
>> Which is one true God?
>> Follow follow this. Does the one true
God have children in any sense?
>> Does the one true God have children in
any sense? Sure. Yeah. No problem.
>> Okay. All right. Good.
>> I got you. I got you.
>> No problem.
>> I got you. I got you. So then that means
my brother my brother Adam that means
that you just left Islam.
>> You just left Islam.
>> Let me let me ask you let me ask you let
me ask you a question. When you say you
believe in the one true God,
>> who is that?
>> Are you switching subjects?
>> I'm not switching subjects. I'm going
right to the crux.
>> Okay. How? Because this is the where
you'll wherever the sign is.
>> I I'll answer this question for you, but
I need you to justify how you're still a
Muslim by
>> answer 15 questions. You don't want to
answer a couple of mine. That's no
problem.
>> I am, bro. I'm I'm a focused person. I
like to stay on top.
>> No man has ever seen God at any time. No
man has ever seen God at any time.
>> Did Jesus worship a true God? Did Jesus
worship a true God?
>> Yes. Not Not a lot.
>> Did he worship? What does God mean?
>> He worshiped the father. Father in the
New Greek Testament and the word son,
the word son is also servant. Show me
that. Show me that you guys
show me that. I don't know. I'm call I
can call Aman. But there is Look, do me.
All right. Do me this favor. Call Shman.
Call Shikman. Hopefully he answer.
>> Okay. Let him come in. Hey, by the way,
I had the same question with Shikman on
how is Jesus is a Muslim. Can you call
God your father? He avoided it the
entire time.
>> Can I ask a question? Yes.
>> I want to ask you a question. Did Jesus
believe the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit are one true God?
>> Yes.
>> Where does he ever say that?
>> Okay. So, notice I have no problem
answering this question, but I have OCD.
I I get itches when I get off topic. I
promise you, Adam, look,
>> this is this is on topic with the sign.
>> No, you're right. It's on land. You're
right. Let me land.
I'm flying.
>> Listen, I got you. Look, I got different
topics on the sign, right? One of the
topics is Jesus is a Muslim.
>> Did Jesus worship a trinity? That's one.
Oh, you only saw that sign. Jesus
worship a trinity. So with that being
said, with that worship,
>> did Allah worship one God? Did Allah
worship one God? Trinity has all worship
God. All worship one. Allah is God.
Allah. Okay. Thank you.
So, so look, if if Jesus is a person in
the Trinity, how can you worship the
Trinity?
>> The most brain better.
>> He's the most Yeah. Yeah. I agree. I the
most
>> So, really quick, let's get back
focused. Let's get back focus.
>> Wait, Adam, wait. Adam, you have my You
have my word, bro. I'm going to let you
I'm going to let you know scared of this
man, man. I'm scared of him.
>> End it, bro. This is going to keep
going.
>> You got to go on this side.
>> Let me end it.
>> All right. So, look. So, look, Adam,
here it is.
>> 148.
>> Let's finish this first. And I promise
you the Muslim. Okay. All right. And I
promise you, I'll go with you on your
question. Okay. You have my word. All
right. So
>> when you affirm when you said that the
true God can have children in some sense
in the correct sense that's what you're
saying
>> always one true God and put three
>> what I what I need you to do funny
>> what I need you to do Adam focus
>> oh we got two Adams that's crazy so Adam
what I need you to do okay pay attention
to the question
>> can you show me that in Islam it is
consistent that Allah has children in a
correct sense Where in Islam is this
taught?
>> This is with context. The Quran does not
teach fathership, sunship. Why? I am
only saying those words because you
believe that. I did not come with the
claim Jesus is the son of God in the
right. I didn't make that. You just said
that, brother.
>> I am only saying that to speak your
language.
>> Oh, no. Don't speak my I'm asking you in
objective truth. Does
>> the way you see it? No.
>> Thank you. Don't do that. That matters.
Context matters.
>> Notice what you did. You said in the way
you see it. Stop doing that. I'm asking
you right now, objectively true,
regardless of how I see it, regardless
of how you see it, does Islam teach that
Allah has children in a correct sense?
>> No.
>> Say that question one more time,
>> regardless of what I think, regardless
of how you see it, regardless of anyone
objectively. Okay. Does the does Islam
teach that Allah has children in a
correct sense? I mean this is this is a
very simple question and I'm giving you
a very simple answer and and if Jesus is
saying that it is correct
>> no problem beautiful. So look if Jesus
is saying that it's correct. Now here's
the here's a you just walked into the
dilemma.
>> If Jesus is saying it
I like you if Jes said if Jesus is
saying that God has children then it's
correct. That means that Muhammad is
wrong. If something is correct, then the
opposite is wrong. So since Jesus says
that God is his father, then Muhammad is
wrong when he says that God is not his
father.
>> What do you mean by that?
>> It doesn't matter.
>> Oh, it doesn't matter.
>> Yes. Because Muhammad says that Allah is
not a father in any sense.
>> That the only relationship you can have,
look, chapter 19, verse 93, it says
this. It says, "None in the heavens or
the earth can come to Allah except as a
slave."
So you can't except as a slave. So you
cannot come to him as a son
metaphorically. Paul made the same
statement.
>> You cannot come to him as a son
figuratively.
So here's the verse. Chapter 19 verse
93. There's none in the heavens or the
earth that can come to Allah except as a
slave.
>> Okay. Was Jesus a slave to God?
>> He was not just a slave. He was more
than that. He was also his son.
>> Yeah. No problem.
>> Here's a problem because Jesus had
brothers. So here's the problem. Here's
the brothers got his brothers. Excuse
me. So, so here, so here's the problem.
>> So, here's the problem. The problem is
that is that when the Quran eliminates
any sense that God has a son, it
eliminates it. You can only be his
slave. Luke, look, just like I can't I
can't pull a verse from the Bible.
Everybody look
all Christian precept. Don't pick a
verse. Don't cherry pick. The same thing
I'm going to say here. You need to read
within context. Just like I need to read
within context. Okay, good. I can't
look. I can't say God is not God is not
a man. Oh, the Bible say God is not a
man, therefore God is not a Right. Fair,
right? Because it says because it says
God is not a man that he lies. Sure, no
problem. I love you. So, I'm just saying
look, I'm just saying speak within
context. The context, let me finish. Let
me finish. The context that the Quran is
speaking from is the context of which
the Christians are believing, the
Catholics are believing, which is God
has a mother or God has a son in a in a
divine sense. You have to have context.
Also, Luke Luke Luke 52. Let me say
something. Luke, you keep saying
something about
>> and Jesus ruined wisdom and stature.
>> How did he grow? How did he grow in
wisdom if he's supposed to be all all
knowing? Good question.
>> He's a human. You're worshiping someone
who used to Adam knows the arguments.
>> Adam knows the arguments. He's smart.
>> When he doesn't when he just to wrap up
this point,
just to wrap up this point, guys, I want
to I want to wrap this up so we can move
on to your question. Okay. So to wrap
this up guys, what we got to is this is
that we got to a point where Adam he
acknowledged that if Jesus identified
God as his father, then Jesus was
correct. That means
>> that means that if if anybody else said
that Jesus is not God's son, that person
is incorrect. Which would mean that the
Quran is false when it says that whoever
says Jesus is the son of Allah the
Allah's curse is on them. They are
disbelievers and how deluded they are
from the truth. in the chapter 9:30.